pancakes are one of the most iconic
breakfasts and so many recipes claim to
have the best so we spent several weeks
and tried out a few techniques and we
found what it actually takes to make the
best fluffiest buttermilk pancakes ever
the right amount of flour is crucial to
achieving a fluffy pancake and so many
recipes vary in terms of how much they
call for so we experimented to find the
exact proportion needed for the perfect
pancake so if you use too little flour
in this case two cups you end up with a
pancake that tastes really great but
it's really flat too much flour creates
a deceivingly thick pancake sure it
looks great but it lacks flavor and it's
really just too dense i mean it kind of
tastes like eating you know like baked
flour
no one wants it we found the sweet spot
as two and a half cups of flour your
pancakes will be light fluffy and
delicious pro tip make sure you measure
the flour correctly by spooning it into
the measuring cup and then leveling it
with a straight edge if you scoop the
flower directly with the cup or just
pack it right in whatever you make is
going to be way too dense now flour
isn't the only thing that affects how
pillowy your pancakes are to up their
fluff factor you're going to need a
leavener leaveners are those ingredients
that allow food to rise when cooking or
baking these are things like yeast
baking powder and baking soda if you use
only baking soda your pancakes will rise
but taste too soapy if you use just
baking powder which is a mixture of
baking soda and cream of tartar it'll
taste like aluminum foil we use a
mixture of both because when they work
together you'll get the perfect amount
of lift from the combination of baking
soda along with the right amount of tang
from the cream of tartar and the baking
powder
so now that we've got all that settled
let's prep our dry ingredients
this is pretty straightforward add the
sugar salt
baking powder and baking soda to the
flour and whisk to combine
now there's nothing more classic than
using buttermilk for your pancakes that
said if you find yourself in a pinch you
can actually make your own it's pretty
simple just add a few tablespoons of
lemon juice or vinegar to whole milk and
let it stand for five to ten minutes
once you see the milk start to curdle
you can use it just like buttermilk yeah
up close it looks a little weird we also
did an experiment to see if using
buttermilk powder would enhance the
fluffiness of our pancakes and it
actually did affect the texture but the
buttermilk flavor was completely lost
now we're going to move on to our wet
ingredients add the buttermilk
melted butter and egg yolks and again
whisk together yeah it's a lot of butter
but you're making pancakes you want them
to be buttery and flavorful and
delicious make your life better with
butter okay this seems simple but this
is actually a make or break moment
you're going to add the buttermilk
mixture to the dry ingredients and
gently mix it until just combined
i really want to emphasize to not over
mix your batter
that'll result in dense flat pancakes
you also want to use a rubber spatula
instead of a whisk that'll help you just
gently fold the ingredients together now
eggs are the final super important part
of guaranteeing that you'll achieve
picture perfect fluffy pancakes i cannot
stress this enough they're also the most
debated we found that adding a whole egg
all at once doesn't actually result in
any fluffiness you should add the egg
white separate from the egg yolk because
on its own the egg white has different
properties than if you were to add the
whole egg all at once the most popular
method is to add the egg yolk to the
batter then beat the separated white
into soft peaks before folding it in
this does work but we actually found
that you can save yourself some time by
adding the separated unbeaten egg white
on its own to get a pancake that's just
as fluffy
i mean who really wants to break out the
hand mixer at 7am am i right now we're
going to add the unwhipped egg white on
its own and again fold it until just
combined you don't want to see any of
that snotty egg but you also don't want
it to be too mixed in this may look
under mixed but some lumps and small
pockets of flour are actually what you
want the batter to look like
at this point let the batter rest for 15
to 30 minutes so all the ingredients can
really get to know each other
while it may not seem super important
the pan you use can radically impact how
your pancakes look you can absolutely
use a nonstick pan if you want its
smooth surface will guarantee that your
pancakes are flat and uniform however we
prefer a cast iron the rough surface of
the cast iron will give your pancakes
these glorious craggy pockets perfect
for soaking up all that butter and syrup
you're gonna put on top
set your pan over medium heat with a
tablespoon of butter yes more butter you
can use oil if you want to but it'll
make your pancakes taste more like a
donut rather than a pancake which is
fine if you know that's your thing
once the butter melts and starts to
bubble turn the heat down to medium low
to ensure that everything cooks evenly
we found that a hefty third cup of
batter gives us the ideal size pancakes
but you can make them as big or small as
you want
this is also the time for you to
customize your pancakes with blueberries
chocolate chips whatever you want i'm a
berry type of girl myself but you can go
crazy
so after a few minutes you're gonna
start to see these bubbles pop up on the
surface that's your green light to flip
your pancake don't be discouraged if
your first pancake doesn't look great it
usually takes a few tries
i mean and no one has to know it's a
snack just for you you don't need to let
the pancake cook for too long on the
side since it did most of the cooking
before you flipped it just a minute or
two to get that golden brown bottom
that's pretty much it
we like ours with more butter shocker
it's tasty and lots of maple syrup
and there you have it you've got
yourself the perfect stack of fluffy
buttermilk pancakes sure they aren't the
most complicated thing to make and don't
take that long but if you really want to
upgrade your weekend skip the box mix
take the extra time to follow these
steps we've taught you and we can
guarantee that they'll be some of the
best pancakes you've ever had we mean it
we can't stop making them
these are the pancakes where people came
running in the office how many pancakes
do you think you made i think i made
over 400 pancakes 500 maybe someone
shook my hand after saying thank you for
bringing these into our life
[Music]